game text back to break down the tech
that dries the games we love and we're
here today to explain refresh rate
demystify vsync and talk about how free
sync and gsync technologies have changed
the world of PC hardware and we can't
have this discussion without dipping
into the number one factor of gaming
performance framerate so let's get you
in sync with these turns
[Music]
first off refresh rate is the maximum
number of times in a second that a
monitor or TV draws a frame data it's
being sent measured in Hertz 60 Hertz is
the standard refresh rate of modern
displays which means it can project a
maximum of 60 frames per second but 144
Hertz monitors are increasingly common
and we're even starting to see 240 Hertz
and super high-end monitors so while
60fps is the gold standard for in-game
performance there is a noticeable
difference as a refresh rate and
framerate go up in conjunction not only
does motion look and feel much smoother
you're literally receiving more frame
data it's a competitive advantage in
first-person shooters where split-second
reactions and input tracking of your
controls can determine who wins and who
loses admittedly there are diminishing
returns as we get higher and higher
I'd say the jump from 30fps to 60 is
more impactful than going from 144 to
240
but the biggest catch with any display
is that your PC must be powerful enough
to produce those high frame rates for
you to reap the benefits of a monitors
refresh rate a monitor cannot show what
it does not receive which can also lead
to the problem of screen tearing it
happens when the framerate output of
your PC doesn't match the refresh rate
of your monitor when these two are out
of sync the monitor can show data from
two or more different frames at a given
moment and since monitors update the
image vertically the frame discrepancy
will result in a horizontal tear effect
when in-game objects or the camera moves
left to right to mitigate the effects of
screen tearing you have the option of
vertical synchronization or vsync it
limits the frame output of your hardware
to your monitor but there are many
drawbacks that come along with vsync and
many of us prefer to leave it off input
lag is the number one
deal-breaker and you'll feel the delay
with button presses and camera movement
showing up on screen when vsync is on
incomes g-sync from Nvidia and freesync
from AMD both of which are adaptive
frame syncing technologies built into
specific monitors instead of putting the
onus on your graphics card to match the
displays refresh rate
the script is flipped g-sync and free
sync monitors work to match its refresh
rate with the frame rate your PC
produces up to the maximum refresh rate
this comes without any compromises in
terms of in-game performance since
monitors with these technologies have
built-in processors to execute the
adaptive synchronization thus
eliminating screen tearing
understandably free sync and gsync are
only seen in high refresh rate monitors
since it's almost a guarantee that frame
rate will fluctuate when the bar is set
that high but this means you'll have to
shell out the dough for these premium
monitors although prices are lower than
they've ever been for this tech another
catch is that since g-sync and free sync
are proprietary technologies you'll also
need a video card from the corresponding
brand for it to work
limiting your hardware options that all
might be a lot to take in at once so
here's a quick recap of everything we've
gone over frame rate the number of
frames per second a game is running
depends on your PC hardware and in-game
graphics settings refresh rate the upper
limit of how many frames per second and
monitor can project screen tearing a
horizontal mismatch of frames when
framerate and refresh rate are out of
sync apparent when objects move left to
right vsync an option to limit a game's
framerate to the monitors refresh rate
but results in input lag g-sync and free
sync proprietary tech from Nvidia and
AMD built into specific monitors that
makes the monitor adapt its refresh rate
to a games frame rate there's always
more nuance when it comes to these
technologies so feel free to take the
discussion to the comments we've also
dug into anti aliasing and its various
methods so do yourself a favor and check
out that video and give this video a
thumbs up and subscribe to GameSpot for
more game tech thanks for watching and
we'll see you soon